Superman has been able to focus his heat and
X-ray vision to microscopic levels since 2001,
but it’s only thanks to recent advancements
in “molecular imaging” that this is moving
from comics to medicine.
There are lots of different ways doctors look
inside your body.MRIs let us view structures
based on water content, and X-rays based on
tissue density.
And, while this can give us beautiful anatomical
information, the standard techniques are quite
limited in what they can tell us about a given
structure.
For example, mammograms use low-energy X-rays
to produce images of breast tissue so a doctor
can check for any lurking tumors.
But they’re not a perfect test by any means.
Up to 50% of women have dense breast tissue
that makes it difficult to get a clear image
and, consequently, there are lots of false
positive results.
One study estimated as many as 1 in 3 women
are initially told they have an abnormal result,
only to find there’s no cancer after repeat
or more sophisticated tests
And,on top of that, the more sophisticated
tests we do have, like MRIs, they require
an injection to make the target tissues stand
out, and that means tons of sterile tools,
trained professionals to do the injection,
and extra time at the hospital for the patient.
But, a new study offers what could be a better
solution… a technique called molecular imaging,
paired with a different way to deliver the
dye -- a simple pill.
Molecular imaging isn’t going to give us
superhuman sight, buuut it CAN make it easier
for doctors to detect tumors during screening
tests.
It uses specially designed dyes to illuminate
different tissues based on their biochemical
properties, giving an extra layer of information
about what you’re looking at.
This new technique took advantage of the fact
that cells in a breast cancer tumor have a
lot of a protein receptor called integrin.
Integrins are found in cells all over the
body so this type of dye wasn’t totally
exclusive to the tumor cells, but it did let
them detect tumors as small as 2 cm in mice.
Which is pretty small.
The thing is, it’s based on a pill.
And whenever something is ingested instead
of injected it means you have to worry about
whether it’ll get absorbed by the gut into
the bloodstream where it can travel to go
do its business.
And while they didn’t have as high of doses
as they would’ve hoped because of all these
metabolic processes, the researchers could
still detect breast cancer tumors and some
support cells in mice.- No injections required.
As we continue to identify biomarkers of aggressive
tumors, this would mean that screening tests
using molecular imaging would not only be
able to check if a mass is present -- they
could also give insight as to whether it’s
benign or something more worrisome that needs
to be removed right away.
Since molecular imaging is less confounded
by the density of tissue, the hope is that
it would have higher accuracy than the current
standard.
While this still needs to be tested in humans
-- and with dyes for different targets -- this
type of pill is inexpensive, estimated by
the authors at about $1/dose, and it’d be
a big improvement over the current standard
in terms of accuracy and efficiency.
So when it comes to scanning inside our bodies,
there’s still a lot to learn.
Mammograms are the current standard for screening
tests, and the American Cancer Society recommends
once women reach 45 they start getting them.But,
I don’t know about you -- I’m terrified
of needles so I’d pick a pill over an injection
any day.
For more medical mysteries,
check out this video Julian did about surgeries
that might not work at all -- placebo surgeries!
Oh and one last thing: the dye used in this
study was one that already existed -- it was
made by a pharma company but failed to do
what it was designed for… good thing these
folks found another use for it!